welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid so I want to talk about something
that drives me so crazy a lot of people
don't understand how science works
scientists run into this a lot during
conversations with certain people you
know evolution deniers climate change
deniers etc I have a few in my personal
life that are regularly irritating there
was this mean going around that said I
don't believe in science I trust science
science is not a belief system it's not
like believing in an afterlife it's more
like trusting a loyal friend it's a way
of thinking and learning this is my
attempt to eliminate the misconception
here we go the process science goes
through is something we call the
scientific method now there are a lot of
complicated versions out there a lot of
which are specialized for certain fields
I'm not going to go through all of that
what I want to do is emphasize the
underlying principles that make science
reliable first you make an observation
basically you notice something happened
pretty much everyone does this all day
even babies do this sounds easy enough
right
second you create a hypothesis remember
that thing you just noticed now you got
a gut feeling about why it happened this
is a really dangerous place to stop
because our gut feelings are wrong a lot
and unfortunately it's where most people
stop some people don't even go that far
they just let some other completely
unqualified person tell them what the
gut feeling is it's very human we're
probably all guilty of this and less
important things but that's why science
doesn't stop there for this gut feeling
to become science we still need to test
it by making a prediction basically we
ask ourselves what other things does
this gut feeling suggest once we have
one of those things we look for it in an
experiment if the experiment doesn't
match the prediction then we know our
gut feeling is at least a little wrong
so we go back change it to match the
experiment and start over so if the
experiment does match the prediction
does that mean we got a right excellent
question and the answer is no one
experiment isn't enough the most
important part of science is the peer
review process see the first scientist
has to publish their work that way other
scientists in the same field can see it
critique it make their own predictions
and perform their own experiments to
test the original gut feeling only after
many experiments by
scientists do we consider it to be fact
only one more 99.99% sure do we call it
a theory without peer review a
scientists gut feeling means nothing I
mean if a doctor tells you you're
unhealthy in some way then you get a
second opinion if the second opinion
agrees then you usually trust it that's
what science is like except you're
getting tens of thousands of opinions
instead of just two and you're getting
them from the people that know what
they're doing don't get me wrong I'm not
policing your thoughts or anything
everyone is entitled to an opinion and
should have the freedom to share it
they're just not always entitled to an
opinion that matters when making policy
decisions as a scientist though I'm
aware of how much support these
controversial ideas get from experts in
those fields
everyone's fine when science makes their
lives better but what it brings the way
they live into question oMG everybody
duck and cover all of a sudden science
is the bad guy people tend not to like
change see science takes the fact that
we're human into consideration and it
keeps our gut feelings in check it's
there for us to trust and we need to
trust it to survive as a species got
anything to add to this conversation as
always please share in the comments and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy